serrés
[Musique]
alors je vous le dis comme vous venez de
marseille bien sûr les dégâts ça veut
dire quoi comme expression à marseille
personne personne voilà c'est ça donc
ces personnes ces dégâts alors l'aîné
chéri c'est très simple il y a des
cartes il rien voyez ou pas il y a que
des cartes vertes et il ya une carte
rouge
j'ai de la bouillabaisse ici où il dit
je vais faire une bouillabaisse dans un
bain géant mais celui qui tirera la
carte rouge celui qui tirera la carte
rouge devra faire le bain de boue y
avait un nom je joue avec vous mais
aussi oui j'ai tué le salieri va être
dégueulasse et ma mère
après c'est toi et ta chance n'inquiète
pas je vous jure que je n'ai pas triché
je peux signer on croit alors à la route
et qua non mais chacun vous allez tirer
même tenté d'étirer tous en même temps
d'accord on tire tous en même temps
attention voilà 2 3 vous ne regardez pas
non c'est toi c'est qui c'est qui non on
voit c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon je vais choisir la personne au fait
ça les deux kelly et moi on va choisir
les quatre dernières cartes s'emballe
pas d'accord et oissel break c'est quoi
c'est quoi les autres vous êtes 3 2 1
il en reste un
le reste est ce que vous voulez vous
vous porter candidat pour sauver kelly
kelly dans quel sens je veux faire
sauver willy le vécu et le vert à sa
place je suis un chevalier servant
je suis là pour toi 7 buts à 1
[Musique]
ça va ça va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez on arrête tout
ils ont une avant-première après
l'époque nadal avant sa passe a lancé
nous venons phase aller c'est le don non
joue pas avec ça merci merci dans la
joue pas avec saâdane enrichir ils n'ont
pas la demi finale s'annonce franchement
il est périmé mais vous non merci
[Musique]